host of ten questions with kyle brandt
the
podcast on spotify and the ringer his
guest is steve smith senior this week
that's fun uh i imagine you iced up for
that one colonel correct
you have to you have to ice up when
steve's coming on and i asked steve i
said
can we get into never mind the origin
story of ice up sun i know it has to do
with the cube to leave and the patriots
what is the legacy now and he said it's
that thing that people
yell at him on the streets as they're
driving by
in a cab they they want their autograph
to be signed ice up stunned by steve
smith
and i said did they just constantly come
up to you and say and he says yes but i
never say it anymore and i said steve
level with me
you don't say it when you're you know
you need you're at the the restaurants
and you want a little more ice in your
water you don't say to the waiter to get
a rise out of them say ice up son
he says no never i said steve i i don't
believe you when you go into the the
training room after workout you don't
say i sup son when you get in the bath
he swears no but he smiled i think he
does
okay so then deep down uh does he though
give the people what they want
uh with the autograph does he do that
because as you know steve smith does not
suffer
gladly on occasion no no we went into a
long conversation
rich uh about sometimes those people
want the autograph
at the restaurant at your table when
you're there with your wife and it's
valentine's day and there
there is nothing written on that
autograph close to ice ice ups on it's
probably more close to two words and
seven letters
if you know steve he doesn't suffer
fools he does not
uh that'll be that's a great
conversation for everybody to take in uh
kyle
uh along with steve smith uh on that uh
that uh pod that drops today every
single wednesday ten questions with
with kyle brandt the ringer and spotify
let's get into uh
let's get into the conversation of week
three the storyline through two weeks
would be what writ large sir what are
you talking about the most what do you
think is the biggest storyline so far
for two weeks well it's it's we're going
into this monday nighter rich
and it's it's like the the the things
and dreams are made of
we we have chiefs ravens already and you
know we had uh
we had the great dan hansen you're on
the nfl podcast who does the
the power rankings every week for
nfl.com yes and i said have we ever
ever had a monday night matchup or even
sunday night
thursday night a prime time matchup
between the one and the two
in your power rankings because that's
where they are chiefs and ravens one
and two he said nothing i can remember
um incidentally rich in his 31 and 32
spots on the power rankings
were both the jets and the giants which
is also a first
in the history of those nfl.com rankings
so there's your two storylines i guess
both the the yin and yang the
smiling and the crying theater masks
were the new york
all the way at the bottom times two and
then the chiefs and ravens are just an
aside to run this back i guess and
mahomes and lamar are continue to take
over the lead so then i guess
which is the best nfc team do you think
what do you what do you think uh is
emerging on that front because even the
saints knocking the bucks down a peg
or or at least showing us that it's
going to take some time for brady to
materialize
um the saints have questions like
drew brees is now shot like the there's
no cincinnati for them to move on to
certainly when it's aaron rodgers coming
in
um but uh you know there have been some
bright spots you could even make a case
for the arizona
cardinals would you the arizona
cardinals are great
i i when when it's prediction week and
everyone picks their division winners
and wild cards i
i turned heads in which i wasn't trying
to do by predicting that the los angeles
rams are going to win the nfc west and
everybody freaked out as if i
made some outlandish pick that the
jaguars were gonna win the super bowl no
i think the rams are gonna win the west
i still think it's the best division
somehow it's happened rich and only one
off year
the sean mcvay thing became yesterday's
news
never mind cincinnati we're under
kingsbury we're we're on
we're under shanahan the guy who took
over the league in about two years and
was the greatest coach we'd ever seen at
the youngest age
was oh no he's done he doesn't have todd
gurley anymore he doesn't need todd
gurley his best two the best two players
on the whole team
are on defense and they're probably two
of the top 10 to 15 players in the whole
league
and they've come out with two great wins
right now i don't know if anybody in
america could name one of their running
backs
or one of their receivers maybe only
because his name is cooper cup and it's
a great name
but they don't have an mvp candidate
they don't have an offensive player of
the year candidate but i still think
they have one of the best coaches in the
league
i love the rams obviously i love the
packers
and this has been absolutely wild rich
because if you buy into you and i have
talked many times
about the aaron rodgers uh farewell
tour revenge tour middle finger tour
whatever you want to call it
it has been a glorious shock and odd
display from the two of them
and uh i mean it's it's it's with with
great malice
with great pain he has he's distributed
to these two teams and they look like
one of the best teams in football
in that sunday night game on nbc with
drew brees and the saints
uh coming off of that monday night loss
and then the conversation
uh by sunday honestly it'll be amazing
if if drew brees can even crawl
uh you know you know what i mean like
like he should come out wearing depends
based on the conversation that's being
had about him right now and i
i would not go there yesterday i won't
go there it seemed like he just took
what was in front of him
and even a goat uh who's got every damn
passing record
is going to take a while uh without the
guy who he looks for
pretty much on every snap not being
there that's the way i'm looking at drew
brees right
and look at it this way too it was it
was easily rich one of the worst games
ever played by a quarterback who threw
for over 300 yards one touchdown
one pick and was losing the offensive
player of the year and almost one on the
road
one of the worst games ever what is this
story line is it one of these things
where people
just want it so bad they want drew brees
to be hashtag washed
that they're just deciding that it
happened because you threw one bad pick
the picky through in that game had
nothing to do with arm strength
or virility or age he just made a bad
pick it was a bad read he's done it a
million times he'll do it more it's fine
i'm not there and i take it personally
because i went and googled this after
that raiders game when i started hearing
everybody saying drew brees is done
drew brees is exactly exactly nine days
older than me
january of 1979 so i take it very
personally when someone says
that he is too old and cannot do his job
anymore i
personally i i have a cacophony of moans
and groans just to tie my shoes right
now yes i'm getting old so the fact that
drew brees is even out there
hucking it around and nearly beating the
raiders don't come and tell me he's
washed that means i'm washed
and by the way kyle brandt perfect
timing for you to talk about your age
and feeling older
potentially than your actual age for the
cacophony that you mentioned to be going
on in the background
who's that which brand am i hearing in
the background during this conversation
i'm glad you heard that i'm sure he is
too that's young six-year-old calvin
brandt who is in the next room
on his laptop doing uh home learning
which you can hear that's the american
educational system you can hear in the
next room
sounds like everything's in order uh oh
no it's
great it's we're all buckled down and
he's in there learning what five plus
four is and if you take away three
apples from the nine apples how many
apples are left
and that's what we're doing here in
september 23rd 2020. that's great i'm
talking to you about drew brees getting
old
right calvin brandt is probably opening
other tabs he's not supposed to open it
exactly
because two four-year-olds walking in as
i'm talking already on television
fantastic
uh good afternoon football right there
now
good night football uh with kyle brent
in an evening on nfl network it's uh
total access
here at the brant home this afternoon
it's a total excess that's it
hey now everybody call brad calm right
then then let's just return a little bit
of football and then we'll we'll gaze at
our pop culture questions that we've
gotten
uh all teed up for you um so the the
slim margin between being two and oh and
oh and two the chicago bears are the
personification of it clearly if deandre
swift clutches that ball at the end of
week one or daniel jones gets a
defensive pass interference instead of
an offensive pass interference or find
someone in the end zone
the bears could be owen too and with cam
performing the way that he would be
uh looking at so far for new england i
think uh would create a huge
uh you-know-what storm uh based on the
conversation i had with you
uh back in the spring where i thought
cam would be perfect for chicago i
understand that that might
wipe out the whole trubisky uh
experiment that they
still are putting all of their eggs into
that basket
but wouldn't cam be perfect in chicago
right now that would be a much better
2-0 i think if that camp showed up in
chicago
don't you think i i do i mean i do rich
and
you the trubisky's been pretty good i
mean he's he's been good mitch
um you know they they say that the
maserati mitch is when he's got it going
well but i have
discovered the alias i call miata mitch
which is a wildly different mesh and
doesn't work as well
but we've had mostly maserati and yet
cam has stole this the completely
different piece of
of horsepower and i i will never really
know
until years from now maybe what exactly
the bears did in the off season and who
they did or did not pursue we know there
were whisperings that naggies quickly
shuttled about
that they were interested in brady and
they tried to get brady i
it could be the exact same thing for cam
and it didn't work out i don't know
but you asked me a couple questions ago
what's been the biggest story of the nfl
and we talked about the teams the top
and the bottom
cameras looked awesome and i it's just
awesome and week one is fine you had a
running game playing against the
dolphins and he looked like he was
pretty strong and healthy and that was
great
it was being down two scores to russell
wilson in the second half
and just chucking it and chucking it to
julian edelman for 170 yards and nikhil
harry coming out of the
the clouds out of nowhere and he's
basically doing it with the same guys
brady wasn't doing it with last year so
cam is very scary i i'm i'm annoyed by
it if i'm a bears fan
and i gotta say as good as they look i'm
a little scared by it as a bills fan too
you know what man um it if if new
england gets off the mat in the manner
in which we're
seeing them and by off the mat i mean
they looked like that they were going to
go
into their tom brady post-tom brady
world with jared stidham at quarterback
and instead the 2015
cam shows up in 2020 in new england than
any other team that had a shot at cam
and just let him sit at home until
belichick could ring the phone up
um has nobody but themselves to blame
especially if belichick
uh when he dialed up uh cam newton
looked like he did
on today's zoom did that uh did that
piece of gloriousness
occur during the window of good morning
football or is that something you're
going to hit tomorrow
no it didn't but it's it's a piece of
gloriousness
the uh threadbare piece that joe
belichick
his clothes we've been talking about for
25 years but today's look
even by his standards yes normally it
looks like he dresses out of the hamper
today he was dressed like a hostage
hostage chic i call it
it was that that person wearing that
shirt is holding up today's newspaper
and saying they're treating us
okay and giving us plenty of food and i
just you have to respect
a lot of people claim they don't care
what people think of them they don't
care what they're
that is not caring this is a zero out of
a trillion
level of caring what you look like good
lord what
that thing it said i think it said i
built it established in 1920 and it's
referring to the patriots
i think it's referring to the garment
itself hey that's the line i used
earlier
that's why we're saying we have two p's
in the pod it looks like flintstone bill
is really what it looks like to me you
know it it
it really it really is like bill i think
got to the zoom
by using his feet uh under the floor of
the car to get there is what it looked
like to me
you know but it also as we we discussed
it earlier that this is the goal in life
is to
is to have such a a good job and be so
damn good at it that you could show up
to work like that and nobody will say a
word to you
nobody no nobody our mutual friend paul
rudd once i asked him recently i said
why aren't you on twitter everybody's on
twitter every one of your avengers
co-stars is on there every year the
movie star
you're not you're not on there and he
goes listen man at this point in life
just tell me where to stand that's all i
can just tell me where to
i just want to do the job and go home
i'm not just tell me where to stand
i think belichick is at that just tell
me where to stand and look and
i aspire to get there one day me too a
few minutes left with kyle brandt 10
questions to kyle brand paul rudd was a
guest on it you should check it out
spotify and ringer steve smith senior is
the latest guest
dropping today all right ask the poll
question
of of kyle brent if you don't mind all
right kyle i'm sure
you're aware of this but two great
movies were released on this day
in separate years 1994 shawshank
redemption
2000 remember the titans what's the more
rewatchable movie
i i i always remember the titans um i
i do and i love the movie and i love a
young
hayden panettiere just chewing up
scenery
as one of the daughters and denzel of
course however
there is no scene in which the players
on the football team or the coaching
staff
sit there drinking icy cold bohemian
style beer
like free men who could be tarring the
roof of one of their own house there is
never a moment
where denzel says as for andy he spent
that break honking in the shade
sort of a strange little smile on his
face watching us drink his beer
some did think he did it to scurry favor
with the guards or to make a few friends
among us cons
me i believe he did it just to feel
normal again
if only for a short while it's shawshank
gonna run away
so then ask him the breakout question
chris this is a breakout question we
have not asked yet we're gonna post on
on our uh on our twitter feed we've uh
only unpacked it just moments ago
uh we did this cooked this up just for
you kyle bryan yes
we're gonna throw this out there too
what's the best stephen king adaptation
into a movie shawshank redemption misery
the shining stand by me
okay um my senior thesis in college
was about uh how to make movies from
books
and one of the principal uh texts was
the shining so this is
princeton this is princeton and the book
by king of course and at the end people
don't know in the book there is no
there is no hedge maze in the book and
the overlook hotel actually explodes
at the end of the movie in the book it's
wildly different and stephen king did
not
like the movie so listen all the money
is on the shining for me
however however that's probably the best
movie
my favorite i'm not gonna lie i'm i'm
sitting there
schwarzenegger and richard dawson just
shooting looks back across the running
man he loves you and who do you love
i love the running man it's a guilty
pleasure that i'm totally proud of
the best is the shining my favorite is
mad dog ben richards in the running man
okay so let's unpack this uh one by one
i definitely agree
uh your your answer not only goes by gut
and feel but
through the uh academic world of
princeton what did you receive
on that paper that you wrote on a minus
and the worst part is rich the only
reason i got an a minus is i i didn't
proofread and i had typos and stuff like
that
even princeton men do not proofread how
about that
okay now then the word adaptation
is is in the eye of the beholder i mean
who who better than
i mean you want to talk about going toe
to toe of my vision my vision stephen
king versus stanley kubrick is
definitely sort of the heavyweight fight
that you want
and um i i know stephen king might not
have liked the adaptation
but that is kubrick's version of stephen
king
i mean how do you how do you not give
that the winner just
because it's kubrick adapting it and the
way he did adapt it
that that's the winner to me it's really
good
it's it's and apparently the scene when
jack
is going after shelley and she's got the
bat and trying to hit him
apparently rich kubrick did like like 76
takes of that scene
to the point where the actors were
having actual mental breakdowns
and i think on take 76 they finally got
it from what i've read
king uh not terribly welcome on the set
was going to visit and kubrick not
really interested in it
king also noted i think there was
acrimony so i think that also
ended up in the script and the movie i
love it i absolutely love it but
rich don't tell me you don't have a soft
spot for the running matter
excuse me kyle this is how
uh soft my spot is for the running man
the pleasure is not guilty it's guilty
as charged pleasure
i i don't i i i am unabashed
lover of that film because part of me
not only loves schwarzenegger movies
but part of me also what was i born to
give away
on the planet chris brockman cash and
prizes so the fact that richard dawson
is a protagonist in this film
giving away at one point home versions
of the running man
two fans in the audience of a game show
turned
uh dystopian is to me
with jim brown and i do believe he was
still jesse the body venture prior to
being governor the mind ventura and
three words
at the time of my life that i will never
forget
maria conchita alonso hello
that's it rip the knob off whenever the
running man is on
kyle how does that fantastic for an
answer it's maria conchito alonso in the
role of
miss amber valdez and it's jesse the
body ventura
asking the questions are you ready for
pain
are you ready for suffering if the
answer is yes then you're ready for
captain freedom's workout
and boy was i ready oh my gosh it's the
best i love that movie
i'll be back only in a rerun only in a
rerun
whitman price and haddad
my fantasy team name one year was
whitman price and haddad
how did they how did whitman price in a
dodd finish kyle
how did they finish oh yeah i think we
took uh dominic davis on the first round
on the texans and it ended just like the
real whitman prize
the future uh alonzo mosley fbi of my
favorite comment
thank you for the call kyle as always uh
just uh
a pure joy thank you let's chat again
next week
remember all work no playmaker it's a
dull boy that's right
too many takes makes jack very angry
that's it right there kyle brent
kyle brown everybody hey you watched all
the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here